i know that
uh there's been like many times over
throughout the history of jackass wild
boys you name it whatever we've been
doing we've thrown out the piece of
information that you speak fluent german
but
i'm guessing still
people don't know that is that i think
so yeah no still it still comes up like
i've gone on trips
i was previously sponsored by monster
energy and they would send me all over
the world
and i went to germany one time
and the lady who was uh with me like you
know hosting me or whatever was there
and she's like i've been with you all
these years and we landed in germany and
i just started talking german to the
people there
and she's like i never know you spoke
german i'm like well you never asked
right and and if if i remember correctly
you're from italy
i was born in italy
right so my i'm an army brat my dad was
in the army he was first stationed in
germany where he met my mom
and then he got uh transferred and
stationed in italy and that's when i was
born i was conceived in germany but born
in italy got it and uh it was german
your first language
no it was my second i didn't even want
to learn it when i was a kid but i did
learn it real young you know when you're
a kid and you're asking your mom what's
this
my mom would tell me in german and i'd
be like no not that funny language
what is it
okay so so let's feed we let's feed him
some lines to say in uh in germany yeah
what was the some of the [ __ ] they were
saying over there like
uh um
pull on my balls how do you say pull on
my balls
um
i don't know
balls like nuts what about like isn't
kitchen coochie
no kitchen is kooky
yeah
kitchen is cooking or cooking kitchen
like your cooking is cookie and kitchen
is cuchen
okay say say like a sentence like give
us something
here okay
all right that sounded pretty good but
say but i want to hear like some naughty
[ __ ] like uh
and [ __ ] is shysing right [ __ ] it's
shizzy and
and we've always made jokes about it's
so crazy because we don't know you speak
german like most people but everybody we
can't say enough about german scheissen
movies what's the story with german
scheissen movies because germany like
the germans are like the naughtiest
they're like the they're like the ones
that'll do the like [ __ ] on my face and
stuff like that
that's where it's come from that's why
scheizer movement came from that
i say [ __ ] on my face in german
scheisse off my cops
just touch it really quick yeah just
touch it really quick just like that
just touch it
before
just kiss it for a second
i can't
get ready this is going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly
kind of nervous are we ready yeah
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram so i figure i should
be able to paint my dick and do whatever
i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're not gonna hurt me you're gonna
piss me off